hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled cost of quality in the
medical laboratory
2020. i'm susie valdez of labrets and i
will be your moderator for today's
event this educational web seminar is
sponsored by
bio rad laboratories i want to invite
everyone to participate by submitting
your questions during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question
box located on the far left of your
screen
and click send any questions we do not
have time for
during the webinar will be captured and
responded through the q
a list and will be posted in next week's
in the event
resources box which is located below the
ask
the question box you will also be able
to download the presentation handouts
from the event resources box starting on
november
20th if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply contact us through the ask a
question box and we will address
your issue as a reminder this
presentation
is educational and offers free pace
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right hand corner of your presentation
window and follow the instructions
to obtain those credits so let's get
started i want to now present today's
speaker dr lucy birdie
miss birdie has a bachelor's of science
degree in medical technology and a
master's degree in healthcare
administration
in addition to being an american society
for clinical pathology certified medical
technologist
specialist in blood banking and diplomat
and laboratory management she is also
certified as a quality manager
and quality auditor by the american
society for quality
she was a co-leader for the iso working
group
on iso 15189 in 2012
which mainly recognized as the
international standard for medical
laboratory quality and she currently
serves on the team
working to revise and update this
standard
ms birdie has volunteered for the
clinical and laboratory
standards institute for over 25 years
in a role such as shareholder of the qms
subcommittee and most recently co-chair
of the document
development committee for qms 20 cost of
quality in medical laboratories as a
recognized
expert on the cost of quality in medical
laboratories
ms birdy has been invited to speak on
this topic
in many countries for a complete
biography
on miss lucy bertie please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
lucy welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello and good day to all of you i thank
biorad for inviting me to share with you
an understanding of quality costs in the
medical laboratory
a subject about which i have been very
passionate for many years
that's because laboratories have budgets
but most laboratories have no idea
how much of their budget is spent in
solving problems
and repeating work here are the learning
objectives for
today's program we will discuss each of
four types of quality costs and i will
provide
a number of laboratory examples for each
we will calculate the cost of poor
quality for a defined
laboratory problem i have a couple
examples
for you of that and we will link
laboratory quality indicators to the
cost of poor quality
towards the end of the program
so the truth is although most laboratory
directors
have some education about laboratory
budgets
those pro programs probably
have not included information about the
cost of quality
so this quotation about companies and
cost of quality
was originally from the manufacturing
industry
modified here by me for the laboratories
but if you consider that laboratories
manufacture
information from biologic raw materials
this quotation applies to laboratories
as
much as it applies to any other industry
so in this program i'm going to talk
about four types of quality costs and
their application in the laboratory
you can see from the graphic in the
upper right hand corner
that we're talking about money in any
symbol
in any country anywhere around the world
these concepts apply the first type of
quality cost
is prevention cost the second type of
quality cost
is appraisal costs these two costs
support good laboratory quality products
and services the third type of
laboratory cost
is failure costs and there's two types
of failure costs
there are internal failure costs and
external failure costs
and these costs arise from poor quality
products and services
so this is an important concept to
accept
yourself and instill in your laboratory
personnel
the lowest cost is to do the job
correctly the first time
because it always costs more time and
money
to solve problems caused by an error
so here we are at our first cost
prevention cost
it's the first and the lowest of the
four quality cost
types because preventing a problem from
happening
at all means we don't have to pay for
fixing it later it's shown here as
two green lights for go
because this is a good way to spend your
laboratories budget
we do prevention costs when your
laboratory
designs its processes to prevent
poor quality results and services and
that
means we designed to meet regulatory and
accreditation
customer and organizational requirements
from
the beginning so that we can produce the
services and the products correctly the
first time
prevention cost is money spent for
laboratory activities that
prevent problems errors or wastes from
occurring in the first place i know i
said that once but i can't
help but say it again because
many people think it's the cost incurred
to keep a problem from happening again
but it is not
prevention costs do not keep a problem
or error that has already occurred from
recurring so you should never say
to prevent the problem from happening
again it's too late
it already happened here are some
examples of medical laboratory
prevention costs
so um this is pretty intuitive by
definition
preventive maintenance is what's going
to keep your laboratory instruments and
equipment working
and ensuring reliable performance
quality planning this is this quote is
from the us
army prior planning prevents poor
performance
what it means is to plan in advance new
or
changed processes and not to
implement new or changed things by memo
work process training is
the assigned processes and procedures
to new employees or employees when there
is a new or changed
process and we train them in
how it works how the new or changed
process works
and if their new employees their new
assigned duties
so that when they work independently
in the live environment they know what
they're supposed to do
and we verify that training with initial
competence assessment
and that ensures that a new
employee can work independently or all
employees
when there are new or changed processes
can do it correctly
after training and one of the last
types of laboratory prevention costs are
the quality improvement projects
and the these meetings
and these programs and these projects
take
time and money but they're well worth it
if they
prevent problems from happening
downstream
now let's look at the second type of
laboratory quality cost and that's the
appraisal cost
it's shown here as one green light
instead of two
one green light because although these
costs support good
quality products and services it costs
money to evaluate the quality of work
after it's been
performed so appraise means to evaluate
or to
to make a judgment on and so we do the
work first and then we look to see
did we do what we were supposed to do so
appraisal costs are for laboratory
activities that measure evaluate and
audit
to ensure conformance to requirements
and remember i said there were four
kinds of requirements
there are regulatory requirements
accreditation requirements customer
requirements
and organizational requirements
and these appraisal costs catch
and correct problems and errors
before the laboratory does something
that could harm a patient
for example the cost of a laboratory
director's time
to review a report of genetic testing
results
before the report is issued ensures
that the report is correct and complete
because genetic information has very
profound effects on the patient and the
patient's offspring in the future
now let's look at some examples of
laboratory appraisal costs
and one of the first is the ongoing
competence assessment
so once people are in the work
environment we need to ensure that they
maintain their competence in their
assigned job tasks
throughout employment another
appraisal cost is calibrations that are
performed
on measuring equipment in instruments
because they support the
accuracy of the results test results
there are inspections of specimens and
reagents before
testing and these ensure the quality of
the inputs
so that errors do not carry through
the testing and the reporting processes
and then there is quality control we all
know that
quality control ensures the testing
methods
are working and the results for that
batch
with that qc are valid and can be
released proficiency testing is another
appraisal cost and of course you know
that that measures your laboratory
methods results with laboratories of
liked kind
for that same method and then there are
external
accreditations in the united states we
have the joint commission and the
college of american pathologists and the
american association of blood banks
and cola and in the rest of the world
there is
iso 15189 which is the international
medical laboratory standard
but the important thing here is that
these documents these external
accreditation
assessments are minimum standards for
laboratory quality
now we're going to shift over to the
failure costs and the third and fourth
type of quality costs
are the failure costs and they're shown
here with two red lights
because they s that signals they are bad
and they need to be stopped so services
that don't meet quality requirements the
first time
usually need to be done over again and
that
drains your budget
internal failure costs are incurred for
problems that are caught and corrected
inside your laboratory before the
results and reports are released
and external failure costs are detected
outside the laboratory by your customers
patients
users practitioners who receive faulty
results
reports or other services
poor quality is not free the money paid
in labor and materials to fix problems
and errors
is money wasted so every time you have
to do work
over the cost of quality increases
let's look at some examples of
laboratory internal failure costs
when the specimens received in the
laboratory do not meet your laboratory's
acceptance criteria sometimes they need
recollection
if laboratory people do the recollection
that is an internal failure cost coming
out of
your budget when others recollect like
for example
a nurse a nurse care technician or a
nurse
him or herself recollects the sample
there is still a cost to the laboratory
for reassessioning the recollected
sample
and reprocessing so there's still money
coming out of the laboratory's budget
for that failure
an invalid instrument run is defined
as when qc or calibration is out of
control
and you cannot release the results
and that's different from an incomplete
examination or test run where there's a
technical problem like an alarm or the
instrument shuts down for overheating or
some reason so that the examinations
cannot be completed
and the results still cannot be reported
expired reagents and materials are not
supposed to be used in phlebotomy or
examinations
and when they are it means that your
laboratory's
inventory management system is not
working the way it should work
so it costs money to catch and correct
that problem
and repeat everything before the results
can be considered valid
and anything that causes delays in turn
around time
like rework retest repair and the
downtime of any instruments
or the laboratory's information
management system
we give one red light to internal
failure costs because the laboratory has
a chance
to find and fix these errors before they
hurt a patient
and that's important but the worst
and the most expensive cost is when a
customer notifies
the laboratory of a problem and so
here are some examples of external
failure costs
customer complaints by definition
someone from outside the laboratory is
reporting their
dissatisfaction with something that
that they received or did not receive
a report recall when the laboratory
recognizes erroneous results like for
example
after a failed qc and you go back and
look at test results
only to see that perhaps some of them
are not correct and need to be
recalled and corrected
and then the laboratory incurs any of
the consequences from that
for example did the practitioner take
any
diagnosis or treatment action on the
patient
as the a result of the wrong results
and then there are misdiagnoses and
there are two
problems there the cost of not receiving
a treatment like for example
the diagnosis was benign when it really
was malignant and the patient
didn't receive uh a timely cancer
treatment and then the flip side of that
is a diagnosis of malignant
when really it was benign and the
patient
received a very um
discomforting and trying treatment
erroneously
and the cost of the misdiagnosis does
not include the patient's emotional
distress
and lawsuits they're not common from
medical laboratories but when they occur
usually due to a misdiagnosis they are
very
costly for whatever reason
so we've gone through the four types of
quality cost
you can see here failure costs have two
red lights because
external failure costs we really really
want to
avoid those now we're going to
talk about uh aspects of quality costs
in the laboratory and work our way
towards some
specific examples
so when we compare prevention appraisal
and
failure costs it's not exactly
a logarithmic relationship but there are
solid data from business and industry
that clearly
show this type of relationship
so first let's say
a prevention in your laboratory costs
10 units i i because we're
all from different countries those units
are whatever your monetary currency is
and let's say
a prevention effort a defect prevention
effort like designing a process or
working through a checklist to make sure
everything is ready to go
before you go live costs 10 units
and and we do prevention before we start
start the work of a new or changed
process in the live environment
and then we add to that we have to
determine
whether that process is working as
intended and those are
appraisal costs and appraisal costs
costs somewhat more it's the cost of
inspection and testing
to catch and correct defects so remember
we have
quality control and proficiency testing
and ongoing competence assessment and
external accreditation assessment
and those cost more than the prevention
effort
but together prevention plus
appraisal is always always
less than the cost of failure which is
many times more and remember i said it's
not
necessarily logarithmic but the data
from business and industry
show that it is many times more
when the customer finds the defect is
unhappy with the service when there's a
misdiagnosis
when there's a lawsuit and you can
calculate hard dollars but you can never
calculate the cost of the laboratory's
lost reputation the
the loss of confidence in laboratory
services
perhaps the loss of customers if your
laboratory does
work for other laboratories like
physician office laboratories
and certainly the emotional distress of
all the people
involved in an external failure
so when we compare the costs of quality
it's
really important in your when you look
at your laboratory's budget to see
and understand that prevention
and appraisal are always going to be
less than what it's costing you in
failure
and that you should not balk at
budgeting
for prevention costs such as
planning and training
and designing good processes
and the appraisal costs people complain
about having to budget for
the cost of proficiency testing and
quality control and no one likes to do
ongoing confidence assessment
and external accreditation assessments
that's
money well spent so it's important
that you focus on the green and the good
quality costs
so now i'm flipping this around and
asking you a question
in whatever country you're from in
whatever
monetary units you use what's the cost
of quality
in your laboratory that's the main
question
and if you are in charge of the
laboratory's budget
have you identified on that budget
which costs our prevention which costs
are for appraisal
have you identified which costs on your
budget
are for internal and external failures
from the examples i provided you should
at least
be able to go to a copy of your budget
and identify
prevention and appraisal costs i
strongly encourage you to do that
however you should quickly notice there
is no
budget line item that says failure cost
we budgeted a hundred thousand monetary
units this year
for our failure costs there's no budget
line item
for failure costs these costs are buried
in your laboratory's operating budget
and they can cause you to be
over budget but you can't pinpoint why
every time you have to redo a test run
let's say a hundred tests
or the laboratory has to recollect
samples that were not collected properly
the first time
you're using labor and you're using
supplies where does that come from it
comes from your budget
and so your budget for labor goes up
in time and perhaps overtime and your
budget for supplies and disposables goes
up
and that just goes into the operating
line items
for your laboratory's budget and pretty
soon you are
approaching or you're over budget and
when you're asked to explain that
you won't be able to explain it
so now we're going to move on and get
much more specific
and and show you how you can calculate
failure costs in your laboratory
because as we said you can go to your
budget and calculate
the appraisal and prevention costs
so now we're going to look at what goes
into the cost
of a laboratory process when it's done
correctly
and then when there's a failure so we
have this table here and let me explain
it to you
down the left-hand blue column that's
titled
common activities and these are the
activities that happen
from the point that you discover a
failure
all the way through completing a report
about that failure and that
list on the left-hand side includes
pre-examination examination and
post-examination
activities pre-analytic analytic and
post-analytic
activities meaning it accounts for if
you have to do the tests over
the first column that says done
correctly the first time
represents what you budgeted for
you budgeted to do the pre-examination
examination and post-examination costs
correctly the first time so you have
perhaps specimen collection personnel
you have
specimen receiving and a sessioning
personnel
you have the testing personnel you have
the post-examination costs of
reviewing reports and releasing reports
that's what you expect to have
that's what you budget for now let's
move
one more column to the right the middle
light blue column that says
additional work due to process failure
now something happened that you didn't
expect
you need to um you have discovered the
failure
and it shows here the abbreviation nce
for non-conforming event and you are
required to
have create a report of that
non-conforming event so someone stops
the work they're doing
and they fill out a report and then they
have to take some kind of
immediate action if a report's been lost
we have to replace the report if a
specimen has been broken
the specimen has to be recollected and
so on
and then you see three lines for
pre-exam exam and post-exam that say
depends on the failure and that means if
you have to do
collect the specimen and or do the test
over again
so of course the type of non-conforming
event
is going to determine whether you have
to repeat
the specimen recollection uh the
specimen reassessioning
repeating the test repeating the
interpretation
and and review and release of the
results
but then there's the cost underneath
that where the x
it lines up with investigation someone
has to
investigate how did this happen this
non-conforming event and why did this
non-conforming event happen
and then skip to the bottom where you
have to finish the non-conforming event
report
not every non-conforming event has a
root cause analysis and a corrective
action
all non-conforming events have a report
and an immediate action
and based on the type of non-conforming
event
your laboratory may or may not have to
have the specimen recollected
and redo the test
now on the very last column to the right
it says
possible additional work for the failure
and in the case of what's called a
sentinel event or something very
severe that has happened or very
costly and having that happen again
would be
just really terrible there is the cost
of a root cause analysis
and a corrective action meaning to
redesign the process
to ensure that
the non-conforming event does not recur
we're not preventing occurrence
we are eliminating or reducing
recurrence
for something like a sentinel event and
then the completion
of the sentinel event report and that's
where the
the monetary units really start
to stack up so this is how
the failure cost elements are calculated
and what we're going to do now is to
build sorry let me stop here and put
this last little quote up here
so i say again budgets don't have a
failure cost category
all that money is built into your
current
operational performance you get enough
failure
costs you will be over budget and you
won't be able to explain why
so now we're going to build
a basic worksheet and that's generic
and it will show you how to calculate a
failure cost
and use this worksheet
i will use this worksheet to show you an
example
of a failure cost for a failed
instrument
examination so
here's what the whole worksheet looks
like and we're going to work through
these pieces one at a time
so the first piece was reagents and
material this piece is
labor and this piece is called total
cost
we calculate the cost only for the
failed process
meaning having to do it over again we
don't
include the cost of initially performing
the process because
your budget was the money you set aside
to do it right the first time
only it didn't go right and now you have
to do it over
and so the worksheet is for calculating
the cost of the
failed process every time the process is
repeated
the money in your budget for doing it
right the first time
is smaller and that's what gets you
over budget if you remember the old game
pac-man it's like the little pac man
every time there's a failure the pacman
chomps up a few more of the dots in the
line
and that money is not available for you
to do
other work so how can you use this
worksheet
you can calculate the cost of a single
failure
or a group of failures you can estimate
the cost because
it business and industry has shown it is
not
important to be exactly to
the penny or the the monetary
unit a reasonable good estimate
still gives you a good idea of where
your money is being spent
and then lastly you can use the failure
cost
to communicate the financial effects of
a failure or a group of failures and
it's a very good learning tool
for laboratory personnel to understand
what goes into the cost of a failure
now i'm going to work through each of
the three pieces of this worksheet
as regards a failed examination run
so in this top part of the worksheet on
the left hand side it says regions
and materials and then across the top we
describe the item
then the item cost the quantity used and
the total so this is a spreadsheet
and it's built to do the math
so reagents and materials you list
individually when you can
each reagent and material used
for repeating the failed process so in
this case
we have to repeat a batch of tests
it looks like we have to repeat a batch
of 100
patient samples three calibrators
and three controls and then there are
pipette tips and
transfer tubes in this particular
methodology
which is a manually loaded test now i
need to tell you
none of these costs or amounts represent
any specific
laboratory it's an example we created to
demonstrate the worksheet
so you have each line item there
and then we put the item cost which you
can calculate from your purchasing
orders
and the quantity used and then the
spreadsheet
has formulas in the total column to do
the math
and you can see in this particular
instance
of 106 repeated tests
the cost of reagents and materials sub
total is
132 us dollars and 97 cents i'm going to
use
us as an example but you can build the
worksheet in your own
currency now we're going to look at the
middle part of the worksheet or the
labor costs of the worksheet
again for the failed instrument
examination
so down the left-hand side
we have the different job titles
and then um that are
involved in doing the repeat remember
not doing it right the first time
doing the repeat then the second column
is the labor cost
per hour and then the third
it column is the tenth of an
hour with the tenth of an hour being six
minutes
the tenths of an hour spent in doing
that activity
and then the spreadsheet calculates the
total
so we have the job title involved in the
failed process and in this example there
were testing personnel
a supervisor who had to um oversee
the fact that there was a failed
instrument examination
and needed to take a look at what that
meant then there was
testing personnel hands on time to do it
all over again
and then um the supervisor reviewing the
action so the troubleshooting
the additional troubleshooting doing the
tests over again
and then ensuring that the
troubleshooting was successful before
releasing the repeated test results
and then the labor costs per hour
and they're just kind of plugged in
there whatever it is
in your country we exclude benefit
costs unless your laboratory's
accountant
chooses to put them in there it's better
to just put the raw
labor cost in there the portion in
tenths of an hour remember six minutes
is one tenth of an hour
you can you can estimate this or you
might have some workload data to show
more accurately what that time involved
is
i know that many of my clients used the
non-conforming event report
had a little box on there that for
to capture the the troubleshooting time
or the supervisor review of
troubleshooting
there were little boxes that said less
than 15 minutes 15 to 30 minutes
30 to 45 minutes 45 to 60 minutes
greater than 60 minutes
and by having that on the non-conforming
event reporting form
can give you some idea of the tenths of
an hour to
put in this third column and then the
spreadsheet calculates um
the labor times the time to give you the
amount
and the third part of the worksheet here
is where we calculate
total costs again this is for the failed
instrument
examination so let me go back
once uh no so let me go over to
the total column go to the total column
on the far right and the first row is
basic failure cost
169.97
and that is the sum of the reagents of
materials
plus the labor costs from the previous
two slides
the sum of the reagent materials and the
labor costs
came to 169.97 what are these two other
costs here
lost revenue and lost opportunity let me
explain those to you
lost revenue cost means you had 100
tests
you could not report the results meaning
in a country that
charges charges the patient or
charges the patient's insurance or
charges
a company for the cost of doing the test
you're not going to get that money
you're not going to be able to charge
for it because you couldn't release the
result
therefore you don't get that money
and it's the
the profit you would have gotten which
is net revenue over direct
cost so let's say
for this example if you look at the lost
revenue cost
line it says 100
and that assumes that for each of the
100 tests there was
a one dollar margin or profit
that your laboratory will not get
even though you did the test you will
not get the money
because you can't report the results and
so that's money
not coming into the laboratory
now the lost opportunity cost
is the basic failure cost so it's the
same as
the basic failure cost 169.97
goes into that place because
you spent the money out of your budget
and now you don't have the money to do
100 more tests that
were scheduled to be in the budget this
is where the little pac-man
eats up a couple of dots on the line
that money's gone
so you've lost the money to do us
a set of 100 tests the first time
on a different set of specimens
and that's how you get over budget your
lost opportunity costs
pile up and pile up until you're until
you're over budget
now your laboratory can choose to
include
these costs or not some
accountants don't want you to
but you can and when you do in this
particular example it's not just 169.97
it comes to 439.94
that's a bit higher that's significantly
higher that's um
that's real money and it starts
to pile up
so here's the whole worksheet in one
place
when you build the spreadsheet in a
spreadsheet program
and the entire worksheet demonstrates
the cost of a failed examination run
and so you see the reagent material cost
bar 132.97
the labor cost was 37 because it was an
automated instrument and in this case
for automated instruments um labor is
a lot less and the labor here represents
investigating the failure
not so much doing the test over and then
the very bottom row total cost
is adding in the lost revenue and lost
opportunity costs and the very
bottom right orange cube is
the total failure cost for that one
batch
of 100 tests that you did and you can't
report the results
so remember you only calculate for the
failed process
because your budget included the money
to do it right the first time but it
didn't get done right the
first time you can build uh your
laboratories
um this worksheet on a spreadsheet
program and the reason is
there's no software out there and i'll
get back to that
in a minute now we're going to use the
worksheet
to calculate the failed cost for a
repeated blood specimen collection
and i did not break this one out into
three parts so i'm just going to direct
your attention
to um the three parts of the worksheet
and we'll walk through them
so the first green set of rows
is reagents and materials costs and the
materials listed there the specimen
labels tubes needles alcohol wipes
bandages and whatever else it takes
to recollect the specimen and then the
item
cost which can be calculated from your
laboratory's purchasing orders
uh the number the quantity used in this
case
we have to recollect um
one patient but three different tubes
of specimen from that one blood
collection
and then the spreadsheet calculates out
the item cost times the quantity used
and you can see that the reagent
material sub total is a small amount
couple dollars two dollars and 27 cents
now let's look at the labor cost and in
the first column
we list the job titles of the people
involved in the failure and doing it
over again
so we have the specimen processor
identifying
a mislabeled specimen that cannot go
further to be tested and the specimen
processor has to initiate
a non-conforming event report and notify
the patient's nurse
that we're going to need another
specimen and the specimen processor also
has to take time to notify
the phlebotomist to recollect the
specimens
and then there's the phlebotomist job
title and that person recollects the
specimens
but then the specimen processor has to
reprocess the recollected specimens
and the supervisor has it has time to
review the non-conforming event report
at his or her wage and the supervisor
investigates in this case
it's a mislabeling event which is
serious
and could cause a very serious external
failure
if this had not been caught and
corrected in the laboratory
so we're catching it and correcting it
as an internal failure
but mislabeling is serious enough to
have to have an investigation
what went wrong in the process that the
specimens
got mislabeled and then there are the
labor costs and hours
the portions of hours in tenths and then
the spreadsheet calculates the extension
and you get a labor sub total of thirty
dollars and ten cents look at that it's
15 times higher than the specimens
this is completely different than the
failed test run
where the labor wasn't very much
at all because it was an automated test
and it was
the supplies and reagents that had the
higher
cost so here
if you go down to the third green row
total costs
we have not put in a rev lost revenue or
a lost opportunity cost
in this case the laboratory accountant
didn't want them in there
so the basic failure cost is the total
failure cost
so to recollect one
patient three tubes of blood
32.37 in this example
and i challenge you how many recollected
blood specimens
do you have in your laboratory every
month
at something approximating that cost
so in this kind of example specimen
processing
the pre pre-examination activities of
specimen collection specimen processing
the failure costs are primarily labor
and there are different different job
titles involved
so
these labor costs really add up
and make your labor over budget either
due to overtime
in doing all this work over again or
just the mere volume of having to do
all this work over again and you can
reduce the failure here by having the
number of recollections or missed labels
reduced but you don't get any personnel
reduction
you can't you can't save ftes
by re reducing these failures
and that's that's important issue
so what a lowered recollection rate
allows is for your people to do more
work correctly the first time instead of
spending their time doing work
over again that's why it's important
now we're going to work through a
completely different spreadsheet
this is one that applies failure costs
to
common laboratory quality indicators
so we can use the failure cost worksheet
for when tests don't work properly
when there's an invalid test run or an
incomplete
test run this worksheet
helps you calculate the
the com the total failure costs for
a period of time for mostly
pre-examination
and post-examination so it includes
pre-exam
and post-exam and i'll walk you through
this
so let me explain the structure of this
first
this is a
laboratory failure cost summary report
in the white row across the top there
are 12 months so this is an
annual report but it will be built month
by month
and then there's a column for monthly
average and there's a
threshold column which means this is
what you would
like your performance to be
and then the failure cost so you use the
failure cost worksheet to calculate the
failure cost for
one incident of this happening then
you're collecting the monthly
totals for how many times that thing
happened that month and you're building
this annual spreadsheet month by month
down the left hand column we have in
this particular
example three quality indicators
a quality indicator is a process
measurement
in the united states plus also in any
iso 15 189
accredited laboratories you're required
the laboratories required to measure
key process performance so on the left
hand side here we have pre-examination
the number of specimen collection events
and right underneath that it says
estimated failure cost
average is about 30 dollars per
collection remember from
our spreadsheet on the previous page it
was about 32 dollars
so we're going to make round it down and
say about 30 dollars per collection
below that is the one example of an
examination indicator
you've used the failure cost worksheet
to calculate
the failed instrument run the cost of a
failed instrument run
and estimated failure cost we said
was about 400 for 100 tests and below
that
is uh it's
the corrected reports so after the
examination results have been reported
it's the number of corrected reports a
customer calls
and says this is the wrong result or you
notice it after
you see your calibration failure and you
have to re-call
and correct the reports and we didn't
show an example of a spreadsheet for
this but we've calculated to be on
average about
twenty five dollars per corrected report
now let's work our way across go back up
to pre-examination the first green row
the number of specimen recollection
events
by month and you can read across and
there are a whole bunch of yellow boxes
why are those boxes yellow
because if you work your way all the way
over to the right where it says
threshold your target performance
is less than 150 recollections a month
and in every box where it's yellow
you're over 150.
so not only are you approaching being
over budget
you're not meeting your set performance
of less than a hundred fewer than 150
recollection events per month
in look at this you know nine
10 out of 12 months of the year so
there's a process
problem there there's something wrong
that's causing specimens to have to be
corrected
and if you look at the failure costs
month by month by month using 30 dollars
as the average cost
for the year you have a nice chunk of 62
000 dollars in failure cost
and those are real labor and material
dollars
the same for the examination row working
your way across
you can see nine out of the 12 months
you are
over your target of fewer than 15
failed instrument runs per month
at with the because these were
examinations and you're not going to
have
any profit and you're eating up the
money to do it over
the first to do it right the first time
you have 85
000 in failure costs for the year
and below that a number of corrected
reports there are a number of months
there
that are outside your threshold of fewer
than 75
corrected reports per month
and you put all that the number of
corrected reports this
is labor and you add all that up and you
get another 22 000 and so
in this one small worksheet
of only three indicators your
laboratories hit
about a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars in failure costs for the year
and i will tell you that as a really low
estimate of what your failure cost
really is because these are only three
indicators and there are many processes
that can be
and are monitored in a quality assurance
program
so i chose these indicators because
they're the most
common laboratory failure costs and i
would encourage you
to start here start with these three
and calculate the best estimate of your
failure cost using the failure cost
worksheet
and i just want to say for repeated test
runs that includes
invalid and incomplete test run
because you have to do it over again
whatever the reason is
so we want you to collect
the monthly occurrence data on these
failures
and remember uh the threshold and do
color the boxes when you're outside your
threshold because it draws attention to
the fact that that process
is or is not working the way you intend
you have to build this spreadsheet
yourself but i've given you some pretty
clear instructions for how to do that
i would encourage you to make this a
part of your laboratory's
internal quality report keep these data
inside the laboratory this is not
something you want to show
administration
particularly when this particular report
shows that so many of your processes are
not
in good control and
what you need to do is take action to
reduce failure
and you'll know that you're reducing
failure when the yellow box is starting
to
start to turn white and you'll know that
you're reducing failure when you reduce
your thresholds
to create continual improvement you want
those threshold numbers to be smaller as
time goes by and then of course track
your progress
and i'll say again make sure you keep
this information
inside the laboratory to start with so
that
you don't want to report this to your
administration right away
moving on now towards the end so what
can your laboratory do
you can build spreadsheets from the
models shown here
there are commercially available
electronic
cost of quality software programs but
they are designed for business and
manufacturing in
industry and there is no program
specifically for medical laboratories
so you have to at this point build your
own spreadsheets
they're not hard to build we've showed
you how
so start by calculating at the failure
cost of
one common problem and i gave you three
examples
specimen recollections which are a huge
part of your budget whether you realize
it or not
failed instrument runs all instruments
across
your laboratory and and that will
probably be
a big number and a really
important one is corrected reports why
because
that's your laboratory's product you
manufacture
that report of results from biologic raw
materials
that's the product you send out the door
and
that's the product that the customer is
going to catch
or heaven forbid the
practitioner takes the wrong action on a
patient
as a result of a
wrong report or wrong results on a
report
so that's a really important one to
track because that
is a failure you really want to reduce
significantly
don't be surprised if you use this
worksheet and you find that the
failure costs are high even without the
lost opportunity cost
and the lost revenue cost the cost of a
failure
will be high and then last
i think it's really important that not
only you as
managers supervisors directors
administrators
learn about quality cost we need to
teach these concepts to all laboratory
personnel
we can show them the spreadsheet we can
show them the effects of what happens
when things don't go go right the first
time
and and it helps people be more mindful
and respectful
of the cost of waste and laboratory
errors
and problems because money spent on
waste and laboratory errors and problems
is not available for doing good things
in the laboratory like upgrading
equipment or going to conferences
or obtaining new software
or adjusting personnel wages for the
better
so i want to give you some information
about
the newest quality resource laboratory
cost of quality resource this is the
cover of the clinical and laboratory
standards
institute guideline qms
20 entitled cost of quality in medical
laboratories
and there is also a companion online
learning course for this program uh the
good news is
the second edition is going to be
released in november which is
only a couple of days away and so the
second
edition it has been updated to provide
for you more spreadsheets more examples
the guideline is organized in two parts
theory
and application and so the
theory part goes through all the
prevention appraisal failure
cost types and then more than the second
half of the document
is application to medical laboratory
examples with more different spreadsheet
types
i said again there's no commercial
programs available for medical
laboratories so the spreadsheet examples
in the guidelines show you how to build
these spreadsheets
our moderator told you that i served as
the co-chairperson for writing this
guideline
we do clsi committee work as volunteers
so we do not get any kind of payment or
royalties from sales of this guideline
therefore i can in good conscience
recommend that your laboratory acquires
a copy of this document
because it will help you reduce your
failure costs
so thank you for attending this lab
roots education program
now it's time to see if you have any
questions thank you and good day
and thank you lucy for that informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
lucy it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in from our
audience
our first question how do i know if i
have enough
prevention and appraisal processes
okay that's a very good question
uh you're prevention
process starts with the design of your
laboratories pre-examination
examination and post-examination
processes
so if you want enough prevention
processes when you have a new instrument
when you have a new computer system when
you have a new anything
or when you change anything
the prevention process is to
have a formal means to make that change
to think about all
aspects of that process every aspect of
pre-analytic analytic and post-analytic
about the new or changed process and
what needs to happen to make sure that
goes right the first time
so prevention is all about design
if you want the word that equals
prevention in my opinion the word is
design
if you design it to meet requirements
then it's highly likely to go right the
first time
now how do you know if you have enough
appraisal processes
well regulatory and accreditation
requirements give you a good start
because quality control is man-booted
competence
ongoing competence assessment is
mandated
proficiency testing is mandated most
countries mandate
some kind of licensing or accreditation
external accreditation where uh you're
given a set of requirements and you have
to meet them
but there are some internal appraisal
processes your laboratory should have
and
quality assurance meaning quality
indicators is one of them
do you measure processes not because you
have to but because you want to know
what's going on
and the second one is it is part of the
international medical laboratory
standard and not
um as popular in the united states as it
could be or should be it's called
internal audit but the laboratory
community is moving in that direction
and that's where
your laboratory's internal auditors
look at your own processes watch people
do work
and see if they're going according to
the approved
process and procedure documents and are
you getting the outcomes
from those processes that you have
planned for and you expect
so prevention is designed an appraisal
some of that's given to you by
requirement
and some of it you do because you want
to know how well you're doing
and that's when you'll know you have
enough
i hope that answers your question
thank you so much and lucy is there a
way to quantify
external failure costs
as i mentioned the external failure
costs are
big lawsuits
um misdiagnoses
those are huge let's start with the
smaller one like a complaint
a complaint is a non-conforming event
your laboratory is required
to have a means to capture
complaints if you capture complaints i
mentioned earlier in the program
part of that reporting form could just
be a little tick box
about how much time you the
people different people involved in the
complaint spent
resolving their part of the complaint
and that can give you
a way to calculate the cost of a of a
complaint
you can also calculate the cost of a
corrected report
you can use the failure cost worksheet
for the labor part where you can cap you
can calculate the cost
to rectify rectify a corrected report
based on the different job titles
involved
those are two of the external failure
costs that are easier
when it comes to
misdiagnoses and and lawsuits
i i don't think you can even begin to
calculate
the volume of money involved in that
because
as soon as the organization's legal
aspect gets involved the costs are
astronomical and that's about the best
answer i can give you go for what you
know
you can do complaints and corrected
reports
and those are the most common
laboratory external failures
thank you so much lucy and i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions
coming in we have time for a few more
where do i
record root causes analysis
and corrective actions costs in my
worksheet
well it's a good question but the
worksheet's not meant to calculate
root cause analysis and corrective
action
a root cause analysis is a project
there's going to be a set of people
you're going to look at the existing
process that did not work correctly
you're going to dissect that process to
find out
what went wrong and why it went wrong
this is usually a series of meetings
sometimes these meetings don't take very
long and you can nail the root cause
fairly quickly
and sometimes there are people involved
in the root cause
outside the laboratory's walls like
nurses perhaps and surgeons or radiology
or messengers
hospital messengers or nurse
patient care technician personnel and
they're hard to get involved
in a root cause analysis project that
emanates from the laboratory
so you can't use the worksheet for these
and it will be difficult to calculate
the cost of a root cause analysis
project but i'll tell you it's going to
be high
why because we're talking about labor
we're not talking about yellow stickies
on the or
on brown paper or the cost of the
markers to work on
whiteboard we're talking about people
sitting in meetings for
hours until we determine the root cause
so
good question but that's not what the
worksheet's meant for
thank you so much our next audience
member asks
i know i will always have some qc
failures in the future
which i have a troubleshoot how can i
include this in a laboratory
budget
okay no laboratory is perfect
and you're right there will be some qc
failures
as time goes on so how do you know how
um how do you put them in the budget
i would calculate the cost of one
failure
you look at your historic experience so
if you've been keeping track of these
over the months and years you should
have a pretty good idea
how often this happens if you're not
keeping track
you can't guess so you're going to have
to calculate
proactively by starting today
and keeping track as time goes on how
many did we have this month
and next month if you have historical
data you can look back
um so you could calculate on the
worksheet what one of them costs
look at your historic experience but you
know what
you don't want to have those failures at
all so
it's not like you want to plan to put
a lot of money in qc failure into your
budget
so you look at how many have happened if
you have historical data and say
is this a reasonable number is this an
unreasonable number
can this number be reduced and
unfortunately in the global laboratory
community
there are no benchmarks there's no
published
data on what people's experience with
failed
failed qc runs or failed calibration
of incomplete test runs invalid test run
nobody reports those in a journal or
puts
that information online nobody's going
to air their dirty laundry in public
so there's no way for you to gauge
except by your laboratory's historical
experience
so take your historical experience
calculate one failure cost
but ask yourself the question is this
reasonable experience
can we reduce it that's our threshold
make that
number go down and that's about all i
can share with you
um on that because there's no published
data
thank you so much we have time for one
more question lucy
can we just assume that failure costs
are gonna be a part of
the process
okay well i'm sorry
but that sounds to me like you're
planning for failure
instead of planning for quality
so i don't want you to assume failure
costs are part of your process
prevention is design laboratory
management is responsible for designing
the pre-examination examination and
post-examination processes
to meet requirements regulatory
requirements accreditation requirements
cust reasonable customer requirements
and any organizational requirements
that's labs management's responsibility
to design those processes
if you're not designing your processes
you're not doing your job correctly and
so if you're focusing
on assuming failure costs are part of
your process you've got the whole thing
backwards so let me share a little quick
little story with you
this is true a united states company
contracted
with a company in japan to make some
parts
for them they wanted ten thousand parts
with a zero point
zero
percent error that's three parts and 10
000 parts they didn't want any more
error than that
us says to japan make us these parts
with this specification
so when the order arrives at the u.s
company they open up the box
and on top of the box of 10 000 parts is
a little bitty box
and inside that box are three pieces
that are out of specification and the
japanese said
well we gave you what you wanted and we
don't understand why you wanted us to
make three pieces that didn't fit
but this is what your specification was
so this is what we're giving you
do you see what that means there that
was planning for
failure but the japanese planned for no
failure
and they achieved no failure and then
curious as to why the us would want
parts out of spec
gave them what they wanted even though
that's not what they needed
so again i'll encourage planning
prevention is planning and design that's
where
laboratory management needs to focus on
every single process
in the laboratory and i hope that
answers your question you might not like
it
that's a great answer lucy thank you
again for this
incredible presentation and for your
time today
and before we go i want to thank our
audience members for joining us today
and for their questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be answered and posted in the event
resources by november 27th
and this webcast will be available on
demand in the auditorium from friday on
if you found this informative and
helpful please share it with your
colleagues
and please check back regularly on the
topics
and remember to take a look at the
booths in the exhibit hall
of the virtual conference until next
time take care
be safe stay healthy bye